my friend is from another country and
she came in she was like can you please
explain what everyone is annoyed about
with this whole brexit thing I said look
imagine if you had 10 of your friends
were in a Burger King right and you said
listen who wants to leave the buggy and
six people will like won't want to leave
the baby and then somebody who didn't
want to leave the burg it was like I'll
get sounded I'll ever whatever the
London I'll get the deals like do we
need it all coming oh you can't leave
about Dialga do you wanna leave yeah I'm
gonna get the deal alright so she goes
to talk to the manager
she comes back two years later
she's been trying to leave the
daughter's [ __ ] pulling up here
so you go great news I'll tell us a deal
to leave what's the deal we got a plane
to manage in a 40 million pound and then
we get to leave technically yes what do
you mean technically well physically
we'll still be in the boat
but anyone asks you are you in Burger
King you'll be able to tell a DA hello
and welcome to trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm constant in kitten and this
issue showed for you if you're bored
with people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our guest this week is a brilliant
comedian a good friend of ours Alistair
Williams welcome to trigonometry you're
laughing I think in terms of comedy you
certainly have some interesting
experiences to talk about yeah so that's
what we'll get into but before we do
that for anyone who doesn't know who you
are just tell everybody who are you how
are you where you are and what's been
your journey through life so far okay
just a nice soft ball Who am I I'm
Alistair Williams some a stand-up
comedian and how am I where I am today I
just went out there to say what was
funny I guess and now I mean all sorts
of bother it would it be I think the
thing that most people will know you for
is the fact that you made a really good
video a routine about brexit and that I
think became it went viral and people a
lot of people have watched that and
since then your careers taken an
interesting turn which we'll get into I
really like about that videos I thought
first of all most people who watch that
wouldn't know this but you recorded it
in central London at a very liberal
comedy club where I would estimate
having played all of us all three of us
have played at many many times you know
95 percent of the audience there
remaineth I would imagine and you got an
applause break and lots and lots of
laughter for what is just a really good
comedy bit right people don't know one
minute before that I was doing remain
jokes one minute before that I was doing
second referendum jokes and the audience
went moving on that yeah and then it was
just I was like okay well I'm just gonna
flip it and I'm gonna do the other side
and they weren't with me on that as well
but
that is a big problem it's the fact that
I went against the grain and did
something on the other that I dared to
do it and it doesn't it hasn't made any
difference it was funny it doesn't make
any difference it was popular he's just
like that's not what comedians say I've
had people call me I didn't want to talk
to me for an hour I forgive you
warehouse what we've done it's 400 word
text as to do realize I might it just
blew me away before we get to that let
me know no it's great let me ask you
this in terms of the the political stuff
because I've we've known you for a long
time
I remember when I started already you've
already been going for a while I
remember watching you kind of do what I
was doing my first case god this guy's
really good comedian but you never used
to talk about politics in a way you
weren't you were never political onstage
what was it that made you think well I
actually want to talk about the stuff is
that something that you suppressed
before because you knew what the
punishment would be or I just I figured
out what was going on hmm
how was I this ladies and trying to get
us out of the European Union she's
pretending that she is but she's not and
it was too funny what was going on was
too far I couldn't not touch it it was I
was so sure that she's not trying to
leave the European Union she's just
doing the worst thing ever polite two
years I'm like she's not trying and then
the idea of something simple like being
in a Burger King and trying to get out
and your friends the idea came to me I
was society it was his idea in my head
it was funny I was a saranam I'm doing
that and actually when I got to top
secret Nikko who's the guy who runs the
show of a top-secret on a Sunday and a
Tuesday he was like make everyone's
board a break see if I don't mention any
breaks it's tough it's like everyone's
bored of it and I was like here but
that's the point
it's like everyone is everyone is sort
bored of it but they're bored because
they're just being told the same thing
they've been told this or something this
is like me and they really know that
it's not it's like the Dave Chappelle
with the judge Mr Justice malefic
everyone know there's a laugh to be had
just from yeah going against the grain
even if it's you know only factual
people is just like oh my god he said
that i'm judy i remember the night
before you did it well the night you did
it we went for a coffee didn't yeah yeah
we went I'm the assist on this one
definitely
I remember yeah well that's my was this
before you're claiming credit yeah Ryan
together we started going we side it's
decided to come up with ideas together
and the next day I came up with my
favorite bit of comedy I've ever done
yeah I would say that's got lots to do
it yeah and then you went and did it and
then I just thought it was a great bit I
didn't even see I'll be honest with you
I didn't even see it as being a proper
exit bit being there's a bit of pure
observation ability this is where we are
this is a ridiculousness of the
situation and you've got that is the
role of a comedian to observe and
present in a comedic way that we all
laugh and go that's true
oh I think I got in trouble cause it's
true I think I got in trouble because
Theresa May wasn't really trying to do a
good job to get us how he ope I mean
she'd come up with a deal that was worse
than the remaining and I don't think I
don't think it took it to used to do
that I don't understand how she was
trying I'm saying yeah well what I was
asking before those but I'm curious
honest because you were not very in my
experience having known you for a while
you were not ever political right and if
I cared to do you after between gigs or
whatever we just used to talk comedy and
played life and stuff like yeah but it
seems to me now particularly a YouTube
channel as you've you've become a
political commentator and why is that
well I realized that they are gonna
they're gonna smash me they're gonna
smash everything I work for they're
gonna stop me doing comedy because
because I want to say what I think is
really going on and once you realize
that just everything else doesn't seem
so important it seems like society's
going off a cliff you know we're all in
a little rowing boat and we're going off
the edge of a waterfall and I can see
the edge and now I'm just paddling
backwards and if I saw why doing that
it's like we maybe don't see the edge so
yeah if we really do live in a in a
country where you can't just go up there
and have a laugh and say what you think
without being utterly smashed utterly
smashed that's that's just not fair you
know what I mean I will do something
about it and show how have you been
smashed just give us a couple of example
I can't make it living through live
comedy anymore I just there's not enough
comedy clubs we'll get back to my emails
not enough people will book me it's
impossible for me to make a living out a
life comedy anymore and that's what I
wanted to do I wanted to be alive
comedian now I'm making YouTube videos
in my bedroom which is fine and I'm
enjoying doing it but that's not why I
set out to be like you said I just
wanted to be a comedian on the stage but
I figured out like oh they're not gonna
let you do that they don't let you do
that
you're not gonna they're not gonna let
you do another one ice breaks at Burger
Kings and and so is it been a lot of
clubs has it been them saying to you or
we can't book you because I just can't
make a living at a lot of comedy anymore
and you know I know that my level was at
where I should be able to yeah yeah you
know I think whatever people think about
your views as someone who's seen your
career develop and seen your item
brochures and stuff there is no way that
someone of your caliber in comedy
shouldn't be able to make a living from
that's definitely true yeah but how much
do you think like I actually met
somebody we were both in Edinburgh for
the festival I met somebody who said to
me yeah I can't book Alistair anymore
yes and I was like why not and is it the
brexit thing and and they went no it's
not the brexit thing but I watched some
of his videos and his thing about pride
I thought was they said I thought was
homophobic and right therefore I'm not I
don't feel comfortable did they mention
specifically what I said them no I'd
love to hear yeah I've seen the same
video I didn't think of as how much I
would get this I get people say Oh
Alistair people doesn't like me I think
what did I say they go oh bloody there
yeah but I'm like no no that's the
really important thing you if someone's
got a problem is something I said I'm
desperate to have a conversation with
someone about someone I said but and I
never have one because I didn't say
anything wrong
all the people who after the brexit
thing they were like Alice you've gone
nuts I'm like what did I say listen
you've gone crazy it's like what I need
to know specifically what I said because
I think I have said anything wrong and
until someone comes to me and says - no
you said it's wrong then I can't have
that conversation because I don't feel
like I've said anything wrong and like
the interesting thing about the pride
thing it's like
we live in a country now where you've
got I watch the video the other day of a
lady in her job yelling at some gay
people saying you should be ashamed of
yourself it's like all you lefties you
got a pick a side now okay
you can't have both of them you can't be
on both of those sides it's impossible
so whichever side you pick in that and
the new society we live in
you've got a choice now lefties you can
be as llama phobic or you can be home
with them you go pick and if sources
well maybe I must have picked that I'm
hoping in your EIN but we live in a
society now where you got a pic you got
a pic not a person I think we should
just go for both you want to talk about
that if you want to talk about what's
happening in Birmingham in the schools
and protest you've got to take some
risks there you're walk-in on a
typewriter if you're gonna talk about
those two issues that's like a Clash of
the Titans someone's gotta win someone's
gonna lose so if you're going to talk
about it it's almost just like if you
want to talk about the issues that are
really going on you have to risk people
calling you a racist sexist homophobic
positive side they say that about
everyone that they don't like well I'm
an artist right yeah so you were talking
about that did you know that this that
you were going to get this backlash from
the brexit jerk I didn't know but I'd to
be honest I did put some text in the you
know there's little words I deserved
some sort of backlash for that okay so
I'm not an idiot I've realized that by
calling out like I think I put in there
something like this
this guy will never work again you know
a clairvoyant how did I know that I knew
that I knew by doing that oh this is it
now but it's like a choice you can
either say what you really want to say
and then you'll never have access to all
these things or you can have access all
those things and you can say what you
probably they they agree you can say
there's a choice and for if you want to
be a real comic there's no choice there
you've got to go that way like Dave
Chappelle everyone's like oh it's so
great the Dave Chappelle
trying to cancel Dave Chappelle yeah
what you think they're doing to me we're
gonna try to cancel Dave Chappelle you
think oh no leave Allister Williams
alone I remember because you did that
you did that [ __ ] and it was great and
you know it was very interesting the
people who didn't retweet it right which
is everyone yeah more or less
yeah yeah I get offended every time you
say right yeah that was [ __ ] retweet
retweet but you guys are real comedians
yeah you're still becoming comedians are
still out there working I'm talking
about you know the people that have
already made it and their buddies huge
following and it's sort of their
responsibility as hell to young
comedians up I'm like hey guys I'll be a
murder for beer Camille I'm a leftie
awesome cool and then you went and spoke
at the brexit party rarely do you know
why tell us I'm good I thought was I'm
gonna write a bit and comedy about
bricks I'm going to tell people what's
really going on and I'm gonna wait and
see who calls me maybe Comedy Central
will call me maybe channel 4 may be able
you see the only people that called me
was the break see pie they said come and
do your comedy for our people said short
of course I'm comedian I want gig and
also I believe in their belief in the
brexit pie I think it would be great for
us to leave the European Union there I
said it
strike me down right mmm it's like
you've got a choice if you want to
believe in if you want to fight for
bricks in it you can join you Kip or you
can join in the breaks apart
realistically right well guess what
they're going to say if you're going for
exit they're gonna say you know Jeff
Ross no you keep they can say some
Robinson so again you've got choice
everything you've got choice you want a
sport fight breakfast you can be nice
broader Tom Robinson and in every time
they talk about you they'll go where
Alistair you stand in its nigel for art
happy was hard I didn't see much of
processing like a nice man when I met
him I mean I'm used to people telling
everyone how terrible I am before they
meet me so now when someone says all
that person is terrible I'll go I'm
gonna wait on me because I'm sure
everyone's telling everyone else how to
wire and I didn't I found nothing wrong
with not approach it's so funny that you
say that because when my thing happened
was so a contract oh yeah that was the
number one takeaway from me from their
whole experience was that which was to
go never ever ever believe what people
say about somebody in the newspapers
just from my own experience and
not just it's not just bad stuff it's
also good stuff people like you once you
become in any way a public figure
your reputation it becomes a thing of
its own it's not actually who you are
it's just this conglomeration of ideas
about who you are the other people have
imposed on you I can understand I mean
when you say like that it makes perfect
sense I'm guessing if the Labour Party
had invited you to do a gig there you
probably would have done it as well been
exposed I know what it's like now when
you go and do an event as a bit naive
when I said yes to the back spine no
it's like what they have you do is do
you perform your set and then you sit
down on the on stage and then when
everyone else gets up to speak they'll
stand right next to you and they'll take
photos of you clapping and it's like
when you greet to go up there but I
didn't realize this before I did it
you're agreeing to all the politics
that's on stage so you have to be more
careful now
I mean I've recently be asked I've been
asked to do enough on and I assume is a
bit more sensible about it I said like
no no I don't want to just dive into you
and be a speaker at your conference so I
said how about I come and meet you guys
and find out what you stand for and then
maybe obvious speaker at your conference
I think it's a smart thing to do if you
if you're gonna do a political event you
need to be sure that you're in line with
everything the political party stands
for but I was fine doing that with the
brexit party because I think we've
reached a point where it's sign or if we
need we need brexit to save the country
I believe so
they physica is a party that stands for
brexit number one and I haven't seen
anything else out in Rexie party apart
from we want breaks it I haven't seen
them say anything bad I haven't seen
them say anything that I will go I don't
agree with that all I've seen them say
is we want our European Union and I'm
fine to sign myself up to yes what I
believe in - you know when you sit on
stage with Nigel Faraj at the brexit
constant instant I got my Twitter
mentions everyone got Alice does a
racist look at the racist racist racist
racist you know put people that I used
to be friends we've taken photos of
getting screen grabs of me with Nigel
Farage and sending around on Twitter
saying honest as a racist and far-right
and this and that just overnight what
before
he was all right and he was a decent and
they might say hello to you now you're a
racist and these people know that you're
not a racist
they know you're not racist they don't
care you're on the other side now it's
time for you reputation to be destroyed
I also found that with my contract as
well as you instantly find out who your
friends are and you find out very
quickly it's a lot fewer people enjoy a
lot fewer people than you thought side
you're on he's come back he goes into
people who you want to be your friends
they're not your friends
he's always of people supporting you
like you're my friend I really
appreciate Francis lumping III did say
this at the time you're irrespective of
what people's views are about break sir
or you or whatever the the some of the
bullying that went on and it was
bullying the people saying kid they
kicked you off a pod car all the [ __ ] it
was just he was disgusting I don't think
it's bullying I don't think it's
bullying it's like everyone's gone right
everyone's got right to run their own
like people always say it's a private
platform it's a private platform I don't
own any comedy clubs and they don't want
to let me in their comedy clubs that's
cool and people say why don't you call
them and why don't you bloody Bart's I
know I'm not I don't want to I don't
want to be like oh please sir let me
tonight no if you don't want to book me
you've seen the work that I do you've
seen the response that I get from an
audience if you don't want to book me
okay you must have other people that can
do what I can do fine okay get him in
get him in but people are slowly
starting to figure out like wait a
minute something's going on here in
entertainment things are getting worse
aren't they a blanket across the board
just cuz it's but the soul is being
crushed down view it's obvious who's
doing the crushing is the people saying
you can't say this you can't do that you
can't joke about this you can't do that
and all the while his team it's getting
worse everyone's going to wonder why and
what do you think we they do that why do
you think they say you can't joke about
those so you can't joke about that all
the rest of it I just think it's some
comedy is British we've always been
funny we've always had a laugh or
something
Queens essentially British about comedy
well everything that's British is being
flattened everything that's British
who's being flattened the comedies just
one of those things like the flag you
can't love the cross the central judge
that makes you racist right you can't
want to be independent for you that
makes you a racist of like everything I
think he's just been everything that's
pretty she's been attacked and comedy is
one of those things and what do you
think that is what do you think me you
know I think politics is moving further
to the left I think we'd all agree the
politics of moon fertile if with
politics keeps moving to the left at
some point comedy dies like go to North
Korea and open a comedy club let me know
how that goes
you know you can't I see I don't know
whether politics has gone to left I
actually I think culture culture yeah
culture has gone to matter to let this
one I was gonna ask you there's a few of
us now you know Andrew Doyle Catania
myself Jeff Francis Lee Oakhurst Jeff
Northcott when I said Jeff Jeff not
there's a few of us who are Dominik
frisbee as well we are kind of ante woke
right not all of us I'm certainly not
right wing
I'm not conservative I'm somewhere in
the center there some old-school lefties
like Andrew Doyle there's some right
leaning people like Jeff Walker where
are you on that kind of spectrum are you
just someone who hates all this work
[ __ ] or do you have a political kind of
more broader view about where you are on
the spectrum I would say I was a liberal
if you ask me I just believe that
everyone's independent some people good
some people are bad and it's up to you
you get to decide that's it
all right in terms of light I think it
goes further it's gone further now than
the political spectrum you know if you
lefty right you do see that it's just
sorry with things like comedy is it's as
simple as people were supposed to be
allowed to say what they think they're
supposed to be allowed to do that and if
we're not allowed to do that anymore can
we at least be open about about that you
know I feel like it's being sort of
silently
pushed down and no one's really saying
anything about it and when I say I can't
really do comedy anymore people's
reaction is usually all that can't be
true you
must be making it it's not I'm not even
out here saying I want to be on this I
wanna be on the TV I don't care I don't
care about my own career in
entertainment like I think if you do
still care about your career and same
look are you not seeing what's going on
you're not paying attention but there's
something way bigger going on I think
it's people need to be honest about
what's happening in terms of light you
know freedom of speech that we're
supposed to have comedians would be the
first people to feel it right and you'll
get an email saying sign this contract
before you make people laugh I mean how
many more red flags these people want
it's funny because I think there's also
a backlash happening so all the people I
listed right and yourself
we all did had a great Aaron Burr pretty
much right we sold tickets people came
to see our shows we got the political
reviews that you'd expect so the
Guardian and some idiots slammed me but
other publications really liked it and I
guess work in this kind of culture war
and all of us have ended up on one side
of it and I think that's why I guess
that's what you're talking about is it
feels like a lot of the people who
control certainly the TV comedy and
perhaps quite a lot of life comedy as
well they lean very much to one side and
the Internet and the internet and Google
and you know about them so it's quite
all-encompassing yeah the the forces
that are trying to hold it down it's
like it's insane like the Burger King
plastic video was oh it must have been
it was retweeted in my measures but
order up for six seven two weeks we
couldn't wasn't going to trend on
Twitter it would not trend anywhere on
Twitter it's not if you came up with a
remain oh it would be number one hottest
thing ever like the playing field isn't
even and everywhere and and I feel like
people at you and people at Jeff and
other people that are winning that
people want the playing field isn't even
and people are still choosing our side
if you like I don't side I've just
having a laugh you put it that way
side I feel I'm on yeah a side of joy
that is
we're now isn't it like just believing
in the fundamental principle of Western
civilization which is free speech that's
like a side now yeah and I always say
that's supposed to be the side that
we're all on yeah
because that's what this society is
about that's why we're having a good
time yeah get a list of the countries
that don't have free speech go through
it and plan you all of this you won't
yeah you won't we call keep hold of it
super important do you think things are
getting worse Alistair well no for the
reasons Constantine said yes and no yes
I know we're being we think we've been
cracked down on slightly harder but like
you say I think there's a massive will
of people that they don't want anymore
now on stupid no one wants more control
over what they say and what they think
now no one's out there go now it's not
like 1984 at all no no no we talked
about no one's saying that except in
Brighton mine I did a preview of my
shows right I did a preview of my show
and Brighton and I that point I used to
ask people do you feel more scared to
say what you think now than you did 10
years ago
and every other preview of my show I did
anywhere else in the country it was like
yeah definitely in Brighton they all
looked at me and went no as if to go
like I'm not racist
Wow so there is about probably so the
stats are there's some research on this
about 76% of people feel that political
correctness has gone too far right so
there is a 24% okay poor who are like no
no we need more of this you know I have
to see that Venn diagram with those
people and vegans we need a new vision I
just like to apologize to our vegan
subscribers we do actually have some
people ago like can you please stop
making fun of vegans we actually watch
your show and like they just don't want
to kill animals that's all we just don't
like brutality against another species
it's nothing to do with our political
views you have any more of those people
Yeah right wing
I think you're absolutely right in the
the vast majority of people are fed up
on the chef yeah and there's no question
about that and I think maybe in a way
the reality is that you know III
whenever I talk to people about this I'm
like well if you want to be the counter
cultural comedian who challenges the
mainstream narrative by definition
you're gonna take a being yeah you've
taken a being I've taken in Francis has
taken all of us who are challenging the
maître narrative are getting the lumps
kicked out of us because we're doing
what comedians are supposed to do and I
guess in a way you hope then that the
rewards for that that come with that
which is you're saying what a lot of
people are thinking but I'm afraid to
say will also come in you've had I would
say a very tremendous amount of success
with a YouTube channel thanks doing that
yeah do you feel that way you happy with
how it's going yeah I love I love making
videos though don't get me wrong I'm not
I'm not sad about the way things have
turned out I'm really enjoying it it's
actually I've been doing it more than
doing it seems like you can do more you
know like if you're doing comedy about
how many people are in the comedy club
like a couple of hundred well here if
it's gonna take a long time to change
the way people think or to have any sort
of effects that way right what you need
to be effective in it's for someone to
feel and what you're doing put it on TV
get get it in front of loads of people
well you could do all of those things
yourself so if you are a comedian
sitting there no one's helping me it's
like what what what do you need that you
can't do yourself you can as long as you
could find an audience somewhere and you
cannot assume you can get a camera and
you've got the internet well then you
you've got everything you need so I
think the days of comedians saying oh I
don't have a career because no one let
me have one it's like you can get one
yourself you just have to go and do it
and like you say yeah if you want to go
the way if you want to go the
unestablished went way it's gonna be
harder but it's also quite hard to go on
channel 4 or BBC and write a program
that's funny about it you know you could
be on the tramlines yeah right think of
a new way to say that Trump's a racist
gone yeah it's all been done isn't it
yeah no it's completely all been done
and what I find always really really
interesting is how we saw a lot of
people and a lot of comedians look up to
Bill burr yeah well they look up to
Chapelle or you know Carlin and all
these people but the moment somebody in
the British establishment goes oh I
don't agree with this I don't agree with
that that's a moment they all come down
on them like a ton of bright that
doesn't make me laugh yeah when
comedians in this country like a whole
Chappelle so amazing it's like if you
wrote any of those in this country you
would never work again and you will know
it no oh Chappelle you wouldn't dare
yeah he wouldn't he won't even stand up
for someone that tries to go in that
direction gets crushed so it's all very
well all plautine people making real
jokes we're not allowed to make me jokes
and no one's gonna do anything about it
I think the thing that some day our
beautifully was that tweet which showed
the hand of God speak and if we can put
it up on the screen and it's just like
it's almost like the people who think
that they set you know the techni
tastemakers if you will are completely
disconnected from the real public one
it's the opposite it's like upside-down
world yeah we weren't the best type of
comedy is ones with no jokes that are
serious that are about the worst stuff
in the world it's like you've got all of
that wrong you obviously like people
people want comedians that love to do
comedy
hangouts we thought I'm quitting comedy
it's terrible it shouldn't be allowed to
happen
best comedy show if like comes back next
year of another show by the way right is
it yeah she caught what she did another
show the next year which Mahmud he's so
hard she's back doing another no it's
almost like you know I like about in her
defense so she he said I'm quitting
comedy she got this show she made loads
of money so can you tell you about you
know I'm [ __ ] Queen oh here's your pay
right
yeah anyway see you
oh well get that hello guys hello fresh
are our sponsors and what hello fresh do
is they help you to cook delicious meals
from scratch every single time I got a
delivery from her lo fresh this week
because they sent us one to try it out
and honestly I was genuinely quite
amazed by how great it was because I
thought it was this like mixture of food
that's kind of semi made some he made
semi ready it's a big unhealthy
ingredients stuff like that it was
actually just fresh ingredients that
they teach you how to cook and put
together it's all there and the thing is
like I've tried some of these recipes
I've made them they're really really
good I could even make the same stuff
myself now because I've got the recipe
so you can actually just learn how to
cook better stuff and different stuff it
was great
do you reckon they could help me then on
merica work isn't it alright chilla have
you know there's no [ __ ] Russian
dishes on there are there no who's
venezuelan either to be honest just an
empty place yeah yeah but somebody's
saying how socialism is brilliant hello
fresh are offering trigonometry fans 60
pounds of full boxes I really recommend
it head over to hello fresh coded UK
enter a special code which is of course
trigonometry and start to enjoy
delicious meals made from scratch by you
[Music]
your YouTube channels going very well
you're doing great you're putting some
interesting content out you what's
happening with you too bye ru is ru at
the point where now you're like son to
make some money from it
these are gonna help you make a living
now going forward is that something you
can live off I'm not sure that the
SUBSCRIBE star helps more than YouTube
because pretty much all my videos are
demonetised talking about you before our
last video was about Isis yeah right I'm
not sure that my yeah I don't know what
it is it could be the swearing do they
not like swearing they love swearing no
thing I was driving in because I'm a big
fan of rap right when I was driving in
today to do this interview and I'm
watching I'm listening to this YouTube
stuff that my wife is putting on for me
because I'm masking out the dirt and
it's all like gangster rap is like kill
him do this the end Rob's getting poorer
and what's getting dropped at every two
seconds and there's suddenly an advert
pops up and I'm like what
so when we talked to Andy know about
beaten up being beaten up by antifa that
is not suitable for advertising but
talking about killing people to make
money off drugs oh that's fine yeah you
I'd let over ties that of course let's
let's send that to 15 year olds around
the world
Robbie fair they do make it insanely
catchy you make a good point where is
all that if 10-15 years ago if I asked
you first people that wrote love songs
you'd give me 60 name's Lionel Richie
boys to meet you real and off give me a
guineas for now give me five give me two
like people do I cheer and I never write
we've taken away that whole genre and
we've replaced it most music sounds the
same now it's exactly the same sort I've
got loads of stuff I've got loads of
thing right before we get bored of that
song do you know there's a machine now
that can tell whether a song is going to
be a hit right just it just analyzes the
rhythm of it and that's about it that's
all there is we were talking yesterday
about I played some of
Freddie Mercury live at Wembley on you
know the watch the video and watch the
audience yeah look at how they were all
in one they won't sit having a great
time you watch any concert Errol there's
such an obvious example of how life is
being downgraded you don't mean like
that less fun is being had guys come on
we can we know it's now I just sort of
turned it around the other way no but it
is true you know especially Instagram
and you know everything's being filmed
for the gram everything you need you're
doing it for the likes do you wish you
could go off in summer Yeah right yeah
I'd love to throw my phone in a fish
tank yeah go back to before we had him I
wish I could go off all social media the
reason we do social media is our show
yeah yeah my career yeah back in line do
you think social media is actually
making us more polarized
it's designed to by design and anyone
can look this up the people that created
Facebook is right it's designed to make
you isolated to make you alone to
demoralize you and it does exactly that
my Instagram you know when you've
forgotten to your Instagram and there's
an image at the top of your Instagram
right but there's a thousand images your
Instagram could show you that's its
that's what Instagram wants you to think
that's what it wants you to think and
sometimes you refresh that image and it
stays there there's other images it
could show you but it does another think
about this sometimes the image it shows
me it makes me feel so sad or so it's
just it knows how to manipulate you as a
person like you'll find there's so much
information on you Google has so much
information on you ridiculous amount of
information when you're I'm sure they're
having a great time so if you Instagram
makes you sad it's just it's by design
Google you give me an example of like
they like an image okay I did a show and
I call it the demoralize er it's this
gig in a pub it's in the corner of a pub
you know you have to excuse me everyone
can you please sit right it's you know
the gig it's around the corner but half
the people aren't fans is we all know
how right I've done it once before and
then I came back the second time I was
like okay I'm just gonna notice all the
ways this gig tries to demoralize me and
I go in there and it's the same as it
always is it's horrible or I come
outside
and I can't wait scram and the first
image it shows me is another comedian
that we all know support and bill burr
on tour in a stadium just at the moment
when I was like what am i doing and I
because I knew about the refresh i
refreshed it 8 times it was still on the
front I was laughing just so the end I
was laughing how do you know and I went
outside in the other comic because two
comics he was sitting out of this I said
I bet you're thinking about quitting
comedy cuz how do you know that I'm like
that's the point
so these giggy's you know it's also
about what gets clicks and hate anger I
think that because of the way and the
way our brains evolved and the way our
brains are wired Hey anger and fear they
are the things that will always attract
them way more attention than love that
right any of the good positive stuff
Murray's sometimes my Instagram shows me
injuries really yeah right football
injuries up someone is in hospital and a
skin rash like I don't want to see this
and it's like you know I don't want to
see this Instagram you know I am like
it's stuff like that that no one asked
for that's just sort of Trojan horse its
way into your life now and it's so hard
to get rid of social media because
everyone's got it
mm-hm and you think if I don't have it
how will I contact people ya know use a
question if you would you go into comedy
again if you knew that everything that
happened to you and the journey you
would be on would you do it I do feel
sorry for you know comics that are
starting there and this sort of this
sort of like like the circuit itself is
so hard to make a living out of now at
least when we started it was like oh
well when I get there they'll be like
nice gigs and they'll be money and I
might be I make a living you're starting
now he must be looking at the end post
going whatever I can't even even if I
win I can't make this happen
hmm you know like most of the gigs are
some of the kicks that used to be 400
people in London on Friday or Saturday
are now twelve right and it's i/o when I
started I used to get on stage at these
clubs a good home Wow
there's 200 people I'm doing it yeah
right now and I even when you've got
that safe now here I was twelve people
and a cat it's funny to me talking to
people who've been going 15 20 years I
was there like oh yeah
I did my first gig and then did another
gig and then I got my paid 10 and paid
ten minutes part and I got paid fifty
quid and you're going nowadays a comic
starting out now they might not be paid
for the first three years of their
career if they're lucky if they like it
yeah I had to do a year of unpaid ten
spots my first clubs in London I to do a
year of no money ten minutes for a year
and that was fine other people are
comedy we're doing that I don't feel
exploited at all like somebody learning
my craft and a Friday and it's not a
night I just don't think that that that
amount of stage time is there for young
comics anymore
and the thing as well is that in the
context of what we're talking about
which is hyper work nurse and hyper
sensitivity and I feel this you know
we've all got career for progression
that we want to get to we want to get to
the bigger clubs and play bla bla bla
if you do edgy stuff or stuff that's
perceived as being edgy that is a risk
that you just can't afford to take in
this hyper-competitive industry because
if it goes wrong right we France and I
were talking about this before most
Booker's in a comedy club they prefer a
guy who just or a woman who does seven
out of ten every night guaranteed what
never fails
always 7:00 they would much prefer that
to someone who's a six today and attend
tomorrow and if you if you try take
risks with your comedy which a good
comedian should always do you will
sometimes end up being six out of ten or
a five out of ten you piss people off
how many times you guys kicking me do
quite a few probably yeah yeah how many
times have you seen me ask the question
how many times is it
have you seen zero right yeah yeah right
exactly I know so I know my lab where my
level of competency is that yeah and I
know when I'm being removed from lists
and I don't do that anymore
it's got nothing to do with my comedic
ability I'm not talking about you know
no but what I'm saying that are using
myself as an example because I know I'm
at the shows like watch so I know that
I'm being removed for reasons that
aren't so I know that it happens to me
so I know it must be happening to a lot
of other people yeah and I don't I don't
subscribe to the notion that if you're
an edgy comic that do you're like more
risky like the people you mentioned all
the names that you mentioned like
yourself Jeff I don't see them have bad
shows I don't see it I see but people
can are Wow something
different this is also you know how
refreshing I don't see them but I see
them get more from an audience because
they realize I got this guy's this guy
isn't saying what he's supposed to be
alone people like they love it yeah I
think yeah I remember one time actually
playing in the London club and I was
very new to the time and I had I had to
spit about why we need a special
olympics for white people and I probably
enjoyed doing it and after the gig had
already he get a black police officer
came up to me it was like oh and did you
got understand this is a point where
I've been gone for like a year and a
half I'm very new he goes where can I
see you for an hour and this is
ridiculous for someone who ain't going
that long right I see do you know what I
mean yeah I mean I totally get there is
a certain group of people who really got
oh that's different
I'll watch that but but in terms of a
Booker I do think a lot of people feel
like oh well let's not take a risk here
let's not why would we have someone
talking about a white guy talking about
race when we can just have someone
talking about the way his wife puts on
tight or whatever you know what I mean
yeah I guess so
you don't agree which is fine no I know
I guess so it's hard to get in the mind
it's hard to get in the mind of the
Booker's but if you wanted to change
that my comedy worked that would be the
class of people that you would
infiltrate wouldn't it you would make
sure they all aligned in one political
direction and that the booking was done
based on that I mean let's put someone
should look into it
maybe there's loads of right-wing comedy
Booker's I don't know any but may be out
there I think the people who dictate
lineups and then inevitably a TV right
because if you get on TV then all of a
sudden you bring cachet to the gig right
you bring cachet to the gig you're more
likely to get booked for instance
there's a whole join of London clubs
where you can only get on yes you've
done live at the Apollo yeah it's almost
like that that group of Booker's and so
they have to okay you all you can't even
get a voice isn't it yeah absolutely and
they're the ones and who have done you
know and there's lots of queers many of
them a very very yes and they all do
exclusively Pro remain material again
there's nothing wrong with that but to
the point where it's just so this is
just one voice but the reason it's
getting weird now it's cuz no one really
watches TV in
so it doesn't make as much sense as it
used to use people you have to be on
live at the Apollo or Bravo Bravo you
have to be on the BBC it's not no really
watch is there any more I used to be you
went on live at the Apollo it was like
boom oh yeah sorry buddies you can I
know comics now sorry I went on now I've
got a few thousand followers there does
it all right so that's the same now but
it's not quite the it's still great but
it's not you know Naveen yeah why the
same it's been downgraded downgraded all
of those things that we used to want
what's all about the internet now I know
that's a great thing about it is I
people were coming up to me after my
show and Aaron Burr and going well thank
thank God for what you're doing whatever
and and I'm like well it's not really
that brave when they're saying you're
being really bright it's not really that
brave because you know 400 years ago
right all of us would be burned at the
stake
yes right now we've got our own YouTube
shows yeah absolutely
we the antagonism that we get from
certain quarters in some ways is a
benefit it is a benefit but I also think
as well it is detrimental to your mental
health in that I'll be honest with you
I've when I've been doing this show this
is a loneliest I felt in comedy right
that's only because you sitting next to
me he was talking about being burn at
the stake
I'm disappointed none of us made a
gammon joke but anyway Gary you've got
time yes now you probably right you're
probably right but like I'm telling you
if if I'm right about phones and social
media being designed to demoralize us
you would feel that maybe it's not just
you maybe people who work in all kinds
of jobs like how would you know
but everything's about mental health you
know that's always like mental health
mental health mental health matter this
was not the way twenty years ago no one
was you know having these problems my
kids don't play on the street where I
live when I used to be when ice to go
and see my mom when I was a kid my mom
and dad's house kids would be playing
all over the place
I said to my dad said kids everybody's
know like kids are stop playing on the
streets guys like there's a real problem
with an overall level of
I don't know sadness loneliness I think
there was a statistic like their young
people these days when you ask them how
many close friends you've got the
average is zero close friends the
average is zero
I thought 8 9 10 close for like my
everyone did at 8 9 10 close friends
before we had these phones that connect
us to a group that's more like a BBC
green nobody it's a good point that
you're making in that we do we have
become disconnected yeah this myth of
connectivity and the fact we're more
connected to everybody then we've ever
been but if we are at ease we're not is
I think was Elon Musk on Joe Rogan when
he was saying it's a bandwidth thing him
saying we think we communicate with our
thumbs now most the time well there's
only so much communicating you can get
done with a thumb there's a very small
amount of it's even less than the
typewriter it's less we communicate we
can forget anymore but really it's less
but if I'm talking to my girlfriend or
something and she's like sure I'll what
happened last night on a text and I'm
like I don't want to text you what
happened because I'll skip all the
details and all the Stan I'll give you a
short version because I can't be
bothered and most of your communication
is with people by text and you're going
to whatsapp and you've got six people to
get back to and if you don't get back to
one of them they're going to be mad at
you so it becomes admin like your God
friends you know it's weird how
differently conversations happen face to
face versus online yeah like there's so
many people that I've had arguments with
or disagreements with on social media
and then we meet up for a drink and it's
like oh wait we actually agree on
everything
yeah yeah it's it's a very competitive
medium you can't get tone you can't get
you know all the readings like sitting
here talking to you guys I know that you
you're not attacking me in any way and I
can have a nice conversation we are on
Twitter or something you don't get any
of those reads off people you just get
their plain words and if you notice with
Twitter it very rarely solves anything
just goes backwards and forwards there's
a very combative media
it's almost yeah like you said it's been
designed that way hasn't it right but on
a positive side like if you come up with
a good piece of comedy you can still use
something like Twitter and people will
share it so these things that are built
to keep us apart from each other can
actually be used for positive means you
know it's not all negative news we're
more connected now than we have been
previously it's just trying to get it on
a more of a human level like talking to
people on the phone I've noticed I can't
get a good connection to anyone on the
phone you know I can send you an HD
video but if I try and call you but like
you know I feel like I'm you know Saving
Private Ryan or someone's back yeah so
no I was gonna ask you what what your
plans are going forward what do you see
your career developing as are you gonna
start doing your own shows that your own
audience are you sticking with the
YouTube for now I think I'm gonna stick
and keep doing my shows to my own
audience like my show how to lose weight
and be less racist I think it's a great
show I think if I can take that to upper
countries and places and people will be
interested in that show that's my
favorite thing to do with comedy is to
research the topic find out stuff about
it and then try and make it funny so
that people will sit through it if you
lecture people and what food to eat they
get bored quite quickly if you can make
it amusing it's a good way of getting
information into people so I still want
to do that but I do a live stream every
night about ten o'clock we just chat for
two hours to people on my youtube I
enjoy doing that the most I think so I
think I'm gonna turn that into my own
sort of nightly podcast radio show I
don't know it's not too serious when we
just chat about what's going on but I
think that's what I'd like to do just
have that little part of the Internet
where you can tune in every night and we
just talk about what's going on and try
and lift morale if you know what I mean
yeah just like you've done in the
century yeah
what do you think is going to be the
future of comedy alistair why do you
think it's going to go hopefully in the
debut chapelle direction hopefully that
is the foot in the door of light no
we're not going down the way but we
can't it hopefully that will snowball
into everyone gets to do that again but
everyone again gets to go now no he was
clearly lying I was brilliant to watch
man it was but and that's that's what I
think comedy needs people that at the
top of the pyramid to be like I got this
I'll take these guys on don't you know
people like us aren't going to do it you
know just crush us like an egg
just keep stomping on you say that
though I mean obviously we're nowhere
near that that level but you and I I'm
sure all of us get a lot of messages
from people going from newer comedians
or just other comedians some comedians
are way ahead of me going well I'm
really glad you're talking about it
because someone showed I'm really glad
you're doing this because someone should
i I'm sure you over whelming when
comedians meet me in person is 99%
positive yeah this is y'all yes yeah but
you know some people some people it's
easy for us because it's like that quote
I love from Fight Club which is it's
only once you've lost everything that
you're free to do anything it's easy for
us because we don't have much to lose if
you've already got a huge career that
yes that it's a it's a it's a harder
thing to ask someone to do yeah no I
totally understand that I do totally
understand because they've got a
mortgage and they've got kids and I know
and you know in the end the day
everybody's got their own decisions to
make but I I know certainly when when I
was getting a lot of flack I appreciated
some people who I can't name because
they don't want to be public who were
really supportive big name people didn't
want and I asked them would you want to
say something about probability and they
were like I can't right yeah but they
were they were helpful anyway I know
everybody's got their own role that way
it was nice everybody's got the run to
play on role to play their own path to
walk I think people aren't stupid they
look at what was happening to you and
they go
well I'm good you should help that guy
you know anything yeah like that I can
see how that would be turned around on
me later if I don't help this guy when
it's happening to him now but do a brand
came out in defense she did she did and
look what happened to her yeah what did
you not follow the whole acid Nigel for
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and then they you
know and then she got strung up later on
yeah and all the same lefties who came
out and said I was naughty and all this
year they were the same ones who were
deeply upset about her being see I got a
problem with cuz brown that time she
said that right I'm being photographed
standing next to Nigel Faraj and people
are sending our photographs of that go
this is who asterisk and then I turn on
the BBC and she's like hey it would be
funny to throw acid at night abroad I'm
like I'm one step removed from this guy
I don't like that joke yes throw throw
battery acid hehehe it's like no I think
that's funny at all
I think that's close to being illegal to
be honest you can't some name someone
about maybe you should show she'd
imagine I am him to be fair right but we
all knew okay no one was like who's she
me well that's interesting so you think
I don't know I just want to clarify well
he said it's close to being League are
you joking you being serious we're like
this was around the time when people
were getting milk sure sure that's I
remember the utilize and some some
people that I look out and I go well
that's just a commentator from YouTube
that is a said nothing wrong really and
he's getting milkshakes Chuck to him I
don't like that I think that's dangerous
when people without milk cuz it's like a
first step down the road hundred-percent
we're told and I felt like her joke was
almost saying like well if you want to
throw battery acid
you know hey it's like can we not but
I'm not saying it's a liquid can we not
just I can't stand you can you can
encourage people to go that way all you
can say hey I know we don't wanna meet
her but let's not pro stuff happen I'd
rather we went in that direction I agree
with you you know I but equally I as a
comedian I don't imagine you thought oh
she should be being investigated by the
police force right wait to pay that
stance the police I mean from what I
understand is you can't you can't openly
incite to violence oh I can't go on TV
and say I don't like this person maybe
you should start throwing [ __ ] at him it
was a joke wasn't right but you and I
both know you intro for a joke
I was joking the police if the police
come to see you for something you've
said and you go on joking they will
literally go I don't know I'm not here
about that and it's not in the rules on
the law hate speech like you know speech
sit inside today that won't save you
that you were joking it wouldn't save me
I wouldn't expect it to well I'm getting
those do you think that's how it should
be how do you mean
no you right you don't know but I do
think if you're inciting violence I
don't need to be doing that yeah I don't
do not think you should be now even if
you were joking I think it's dangerous
okay if someone throws acid at one of
these guys none of course you know but
it might be hard to link go well maybe
where'd you find the idea it's the only
area of disagreement we've had so far so
I'm curious de Lorean good ol social
media slow George Carlin right he had a
whole routine which was called here's a
list of people who should be killed
right Bill Hicks he's on the list I
can't remember now they're all
irrelevant
yeah Bill Hicks had a whole routine
about how if you're in marketing or
advertising kill yourself right I'm not
joking kill yourself really yeah so I
think comedians have always joked with
these ideas and I think it's dangerous
to go down the path of saying well yeah
sure it's a joke but we're living in
this kind of dangerous situation
therefore I think comedians need to just
we I personally this is my opinion is we
need to just stand as one whenever
anyone comes after anyone who's a
comedian for a joke that they told
whatever the joke is to a large extent
obviously if they've gone out and just
been overtly racist and stupid yeah
that's a different thing but I thought
it was a bad joke I thought it was
ill-advised in that context but I
defended her because I just think
comedians should have the right to play
with ideas even if they make really bad
mistakes
everyone's selfish you know I guess
because I was in a position where I was
being photographed standing next to
Hyman Faraj and I felt like we was
living in an atmosphere like yeah let's
start throwing more things I'm like hey
guess what I'm not on that bus like you
know my own personal safety I'm like no
oh yeah please stop her saying that you
can just maybe that's just me being
selfish but I never thought we'd get in
I'd never get in a scenario where it was
coming to this level
you know I thought people would always
solve things in a polite discourse
kind of way that makes sense yeah I
thought we'd be saying night maybe we
should be throwing stuff it does always
seem that it's always it does seem to be
going one way if you know i mean the the
incitements to ramp it up all does seem
to be coming from the left I don't see
anyone on the rights and its ramp things
up you know let's start and throw in
stuff
does that make sense yeah absolutely
yeah absolutely
I think it's passion in this country in
America there is some evidence that
there are some far-right [ __ ] violent
groups is right yeah well I think in
this country there's very little of that
from what I've seen Andy knows as an
example where yeah yeah how do you still
think you're the good guys you watch
that video
well we're obviously we know then yeah I
don't see the other side to that I don't
see gangs of people from the other side
going around and we're someone we can
hit I haven't seen it
if it's happening I haven't seen it but
it did is does seem to be coming from
the other side and they're not shy about
it so yes what we do yeah by the bus and
we're gonna rough him up you take that
video of Andy being beaten up and you go
okay there's a there's a tiny little guy
here and then there's a bunch of black
clad people with helmets and bags let's
work out which one of those may be the
fascists is it the little guy being
beaten for being a journalist or is it
the guys who are trying to stop him from
reporting on what happened once if he's
got the wrong ideas well that's actually
it was a Tim Paul video on that though I
saw where Andy was coming out and saying
he was describing anti far as the
terrorists sovereign and this and all
these horrible names and temple was
defending moon saying well I think
that's a little over exaggerated I'm
like yeah because they haven't hit you
in the head pipe like that's what I mean
that changes your perspective on it when
all of a sudden there's a gang of people
attacking you your perspective changes
to honor this is this is coming from
that side I've I've got a brain injury
alright you know what I mean yeah if it
starts to become practical doesn't
theory and I think we've actually come
to the end
yeah the
good ending yes I'll do the final so
what is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be talking about just in
general terms just that the general
decline of morality you know I mean the
general just overall decline in morality
right people don't treat each other as
nice or as well or as decently as they
used to and I think it's because you
know that that side of our nature is not
being pushed on the front you know we've
always been told how different we are
now saying this is wrong and saying I
watched a video yesterday on how saying
the word guys is offensive
like literally they're trying to program
people like if you said guys you're a
bad person you need to have were myself
it's like we can't live in this world
there's too many traps to fall into
right and I think I think the people
doing that sort of thing I think they
know that it's wrong I don't think
they're trying to help anymore
I think they're deliberately trying to
make everyone feel like they're a bad
person I don't think you are especially
not if you said the word guys you know
well on that happy note sorry no I know
it's oh no malice - thank you so much
for coming on where can people find you
online on all these horrible social
media forms my youtube channel please
it's Alice
Williams comedian or if you want to just
search Brax at Burger King that should
find you to me as well because it's
quite difficult to search me on social
media but yeah
Alistair Williams comedian YouTube
channels where I'd like you to go yeah
check out alice's twitter as well as
always follow us on all the social media
as well at trigger pod and that's pretty
much it leave us an iSight review if you
can and we will see you in a week from
now with another brilliant episode
thanks a lot guys see you next week bye
bye guys just to let you know my show
all well that ends well which i
advertised earlier the Bill Murray that
is now very close to selling out so
we've had to open up another day I will
be doing it again with Francis M seeing
again on the 24th of November the links
in the description I'm also coming to
Cambridge in in November as well so
check that out absolutely please come
down it's going to be a great show when
I'm on and then when Constantine's on
you just enjoy the interval there is no
interval by the way so it's just the
mean Francis will see that thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word
[Music]